[Applause]
what
makes a girl a hoe right
because rush limbaugh if you guys don't
know who rush limbaugh is do you know
who wrestling
is i do but that's cause i'm old that's
right so for you youngans rush limbaugh
is like
um i don't know like howard stern
without robin
howard robin's not allowed anywhere near
the
he's been studio to get me on his show
for a minute by the way really oh yeah
dude like i was getting a new email like
every week from like his producers and
[ __ ] like that but he's this huge
big like a conservative uh talk radio
guy
right yeah and wild boy yeah wild boy he
hasn't tried to get me on the show at
all and it's probably because you're
more famous but also other things
what do you think of this i don't know
maybe just [ __ ] outfit
that's terrifying he sees bombs in his
outfit for sure 100
sure okay so um right now we have a
situation where he's
i believe it could be taken out of
context
i don't know how you would do that
called kamala harris a ho
yeah and there's a lot of pushback to
this because she's obviously a vp
nomination
um and i don't know famous and
i don't know whatever accomplish it
accomplish etc but
what constitutes as a whole let's
talk i and listen
listen kamala harris yeah
did [ __ ] mayor willie brown
how old was she 29 and how old was he 60
while he was married now
i'm not calling kamal harris a hoe but
would
mrs willie brown refer to kamala harris
as a whole
in that situation i gotta see miss
willie brown first
so how good she looks is dependent on
her hodom
wow al wow you are such a chauvinist
apparently bill clinton called willie
brown slick willie brown
and if bill clinton is calling you a man
[ __ ] then you'd definitely
[Applause]
enough that's a problem i mean he mass
like let's try
that's dry willy bill bro nah he's
skating on them epstein charges son
i guess can we can we blame
can we blame him are we gonna look at al
are we gonna look at a black woman woman
and say she deserve to get cheated on is
that what you're saying right now
wow can we just be grateful the mayor of
san francisco is into women can we just
do that
can we just take a moment and reflect on
that for a second
yeah we need more minorities in office
that's it he was trying to get them to
suck his dick but it's okay at least
they're in the room
at least they're in the office now
apparently
he gave he did the right thing he gave
his side piece
you know a better life he gave her some
opportunity some jobs maybe she deserved
them
maybe she earned them so maybe she
earned him off her skill and then
also was playing with the slick willie
right but if you're the wife
or any of the wives friends are you
referring to her as a whole back then we
don't
gotta talk about current kamala maybe
it's just short maybe hoe was just short
for home
wrecker which is kind of definitionally
correct
if their marriage split up because of
this affair i don't know where you got
the record but i liked the home part you
got home
you got now i know you know how to spell
better than i do but the home
i got you home record okay that's a home
record got you okay okay so it's a
possibility i'm just
saying is it that far off is it that
crazy
to call her a whole now maybe but back
in the day you could throw hoe around
yeah no he said it like two days ago but
yeah yeah i'm with you
he called the ticket joe and the ho
which is kind of boris for a white wait
the ticket
he joe biden oh i thought we were
talking about yourself yeah
okay he called the democratic
presidential ticket joe in the hope
right and then he said she slept her way
to the top that's basically a hoe he
like says she's a hoe
yeah now you can't take away from her
accomplishments but here's what i will
say
yeah monica lewinsky we all understand
and we give a pass to her now because
and i'm not gonna debate her but the
point is
she was like 21 22 she was with the
president of the united states
she was young and impressionable and
this is a very powerful man
and so it's much more on bill yeah i
can't apply the same [ __ ] to a 29 year
old woman
sleeping with the [ __ ] mayor you're
29.
i don't know if he was mayor back then
maybe we could do a little double check
but that
ain't no president that's true so the
same rules that we for we understand
monica lewinsky forgive her for we can't
give that
forgiveness to come is it crazy to throw
the whole
now maybe al absolutely so it's crazy
yes it's crazy what back in the day you
she couldn't be like y'all i had a whole
face i was just smoking
back in the day but you can't call her a
hoe now that's what i'm saying
so that's why it's crazy when is this
what is the statute of limitations
yo when does your whole wear off that's
a great question
the moment you stopped being all right
because i'm no longer at home so the
second you stop being a ho
you're not whole now now now let's talk
about it okay
let's talk about
wherever you go with that mark where are
you going no now i'm just thinking like
anytime you stop doing something does
that mean you're not the thing anymore
exactly so the second you stop [ __ ]
guys al
are you no longer gay
the second you stop [ __ ] guys like
the second you just
pull out the second your dick
is removed from the rectum yeah you're
no longer
[ __ ] vag yeah you're no longer gay i
don't know
dude sometimes it's in you it's who you
are no you're not going to church you
stop being crazy you always have this
opinion i just want to know have you
always had this
absolutely you really you [ __ ] a lot of
white girls
yeah that's open-minded okay what about
your girl so the
your girl cheats on you the second she
stops cheating on you she's no longer a
hoe no you can't carry that hotel
because cheating infidelity now you're
adding like later stuff you break up you
won't call her a whole you don't have to
stay together she betrayed your trust i
get that
relationship is fractured any girl
cheated on me as a whole for her life
for her whole life al operates her whole
life
her whole life she's a hoe you you you
believe otherwise
yeah she hops off the dick and all of a
sudden she's saint again
i mean i think a whole lot of these
marriage changes there's some marriages
that
get past the cheating they get past it
but you still look at that whole like
you can't you can't look at this chin
[ __ ] like how could she
cheat [ __ ] yeah but eventually you
gotta erase it
you gotta erase the whole eventually the
whole goes yo can i tell y'all something
that's mad vulnerable and i should not
share at all
you ever like [ __ ] a girl so good her
legs shake after sex
yeah every time yes side no
but you know what i'm talking about like
you finally like orgasm so many times
that leg shake
bro i [ __ ] my girl the other day bro
my legs are shaking
so i should film apathetics
yo i'm literally covered in my own [ __ ]
because i just came on my belly
and my legs are wobbling a little bit
did you try to get up
i don't know what was happening i think
it was the altitude
so i was weird [ __ ] happened when i was
having sex up in aspen bro i started
tearing because i was so tired after
this [ __ ]
this bro not even after sex was during
the sex you know when you're
so exhausted you cry a little no no well
i do
nope she was riding me is happening
right now
so it's the altitude it's 11 000 square
feet
or something what so but i literally
started tearing
and i had to go like this you need to go
back over to get your dick back so
you need to go back i left it over there
did your girl say some [ __ ] to you while
your legs were shaking like yeah i did
that yeah
y'all know how little i have sexy y'all
assumed it was the same time having sex
with both of those
yeah that's a traumatic moment bro
no no it was traumatic but it could be
altitude because when you bake at a
higher altitude you have to change the
baking recipe
exactly what the [ __ ] does that mean i
don't even see how that fries
i just wanted to throw out a little fact
he knows about altitude
i'm bailing him out we get it you saw a
youtube video about bacon
hoe
i just don't think it's the craziest
thing to say because i think there's so
many women out here that are defending
kamala and saying that this guy's an
[ __ ] for calling her a hoe
when they have called far lesser women
hoes right you call the kardashians hoes
they [ __ ] four people
that they're all in relationships with
how are they all hoes every kardashian's
a whole they just [ __ ] people they're
in relationships with
but kamala [ __ ] a merry man
and all of a sudden oh my god how could
you dare speak about a woman of color
like this kardashians are women of color
they are bro that's my brown eyed girl
what are they called
brown skin girls bro it's about
brown skins yeah what brown sugar you
talking about the cardinals
no but for real talk and all these dudes
out here calling every girl a hoe that
walks past them
when they holler and they don't lit and
the girl doesn't listen yeah every girls
are whole
but now rush limbaugh says that about
kamala
and all of a sudden they're like oh my
god how could you ever speak about a
woman like that all i'm trying to say is
you're all a bunch of [ __ ] hypocrites
i'm not calling kamala ho
but she [ __ ] my man yo what
but if she [ __ ] my man while we was
married yo
yeah anybody breaks up my marriage
that's a [ __ ] i hate that
[ __ ] for life i'm calling them
every name in the book
yo that's true what if they had the jada
will situation
oh open yeah i don't think they're
married you think the mayor's gonna have
an open relationship in san francisco
aids riddled san francisco is gonna have
an open relationship bro
that's a good ass come on that [ __ ] was
riddled bro yeah but back then didn't
they think that was just the gay drug
say what a gay disease gay virus yeah it
used to be called grid which is like gay
something immuno disease or some [ __ ]
like that it was it was like gay in it
hiv used to be all grid i don't know
really yeah is everybody just trying to
top
each other's gateness right now son yeah
he knows about bacon you crying wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait
i'm in gay so let's get that [ __ ]
that's all that is you tear i was coming
out my eyes bro that's
it dog it's salty it's the same [ __ ] get
your [ __ ] relationships right
real talk start making more love yo
y'all making lust start making more love
that's good
all right crying doing the stinky leg in
bed and [ __ ]
so that's what i started doing to make
it look like my legs are just shaking
candy sweet goodness
wow boy boys man now y'all wild boys
bunch of y'all bunch of hoes
y'all a bunch of hoes too nah man i got
a factory in a hole you know
okay i got a factory on some of the
kamala [ __ ] okay go so she
dated san francisco mayor and state
assembly speaker willie brown for a
period of time in 94-95
but technically he was estranged from
his wife for over a decade
oh come on son they broke up this is
according to this that apparently
that sounds like some whole [ __ ] to me
that's what i'm talking about
[Applause]